what's going on in London well to know
some small event known as the Olympic
Games is going on in London at the
moment and last night in particular
there was a 100 meter final and a Usain
Bolt winning it in a nine point six
three seconds well it was a little bit
less really if you if you include some
of the relativistic effects from from
Einstein's theory of relativity so I
guess that's what we're going to talk
about
all right so George do draw a picture of
the race yeah okay I'll do this so of
course you've got here we are in the
Olympic Stadium in London
there's my racetrack okay it's a 100
meters long the guy started down here
right and then they they leg that along
the track so let's do a little picture
so this is a I say this is Tyson Gay or
something right and then somewhere out
in front of him we've got air we've got
Usain Bolt's so he's saying bar front
and a bunch of the other guys sort of on
room okay so you say involved went past
the finishing line in nine point six
three seconds according to the stadium
clock so let's make that clear the
stadium clock now what I want you to
imagine is the Usain Bolt this is this
is you saying here it's got a little
watch on okay so this is watch so it's
as Usain Bolt's clock so what does Usain
Bolt's clock or what did you say BOTS
clock read at the moment that he crossed
the the finishing line now you might
think well well it's nine point six
three seconds but it's not it's actually
a little bit less than that it's nine
point six three seconds less about more
or less five millionths of a nanosecond
so if he actually clocked according to
his clock five minutes of a nanosecond
less than the stadium clock less than
this nine point six three seconds okay
so a nanosecond is ten to the minus nine
seconds so if you do it in the American
billions that's a billionth of a second
and then it's a millionth of a billionth
nor point naught naught naught such
three knots naught naught naught naught
naught you know I got twelve
Dean about fifty but I want
four five six seven eight nine so Usain
Bolt's have you actually looked at his
watch it would have read this it would
have read nine point six two nine nine
nine nine nine nine nine well this is
all because of special relativity
Einstein's theory of special relativity
so what was the key thing about
Einstein's theory it's a lot of people
say it's that oh you can't travel faster
than light and and that's true but
that's not the most important thing
about it the most important thing about
it is that everybody agrees that light
travels at about 300 million meters per
second in a vacuum
that's the most important thing
everybody agrees on that no matter
whether they're moving relative to it or
not so this really changes how you think
about velocities and how you think about
time in a really fundamental way and
sort of to illustrate that imagine you
know you've got you're going along the
motorway and you're going in a car at 70
miles an hour and the guy's going in the
opposite direction at 70 miles an hour
relative to the road as well then you
would say well what's the relative speed
of you to the other car and you'd say of
what would you say is 140 that's what
most people that answer but actually
that's not quite right that's almost
right it's a little bit less than 140
and to see that it it can't quite be the
right answer
consider what would happen if the other
car was going along at the speed of
light okay then you would be saying okay
what's our relative speed well is it the
speed of light plus 70 miles per hour
well no it can't be because everybody
agrees that something going to speed
alike goes this feeling like so you've
clearly got to change what you think
about velocities what you think about
time okay so what actually happens is
that you know when somebody's moving
relative to something else it's that
their clock slows down and it slows down
by by a particular factor so if we were
to work out what Usain Bolt's time is
t-bolt and we were to compare it to T
Stadium this is the time measured by
Usain Bolt on his clock this is the time
measured by the stadium clock which is
this one
okay and they differ by a factor they're
not the same they differ by this factor
its square root of one minus V squared
over C squared now V here is Usain
Bolt's velocity relative speed relative
to the track okay and C of course is the
speed of light so this is a very small
number this VX square over C square but
it's not zero and these would only be
equal if it were zero so what we can do
is if we want to sort of to get this of
this approximation that we've got here
well we do a little sort of a bit of a
mathematical trick here we do what's
called a Taylor expansion on this thing
because this is this is something that's
very small as V squared over C squared
so we can do a Taylor expansion and we
can approximate this by 1 minus 1/2 V
squared over C squared times T Stadium
okay I'll have to lock your Tarla okay
so I'm going to put that in so that's 2
9 9 7 9 2 4 5 8 that's probably not
exactly eyeless but you can have to make
do with that four five eight five point
seven seven times ten to the minus
fifteen when I did this L did it sort of
essentially very quickly approximating
things but actually maybe I should've
done it bit more rapidly and this should
be a seven eight there so this is the
number that you same bar actually
actually ran the time that he plucked on
it on his watch which is nine point six
two nine nine nine ninety nine I got
four to two seconds and that's the time
that he actually would have clocked on
it on his clock now there's actually
something even more remark about this
when you actually think about the
implication you could ask the question
so okay so he's running in a shorter
time it would seem does that mean he ran
faster in some ways is that the
implication and no it doesn't mean that
because the laws of relativity don't
allow that basically you know Usain
Bolt's running at roughly 10 meters per
second relative to the track and just by
the laws of relativity the track is
moving at about 10 meters per second
relative to Usain Bolt's just completely
quickly equivalent
so there is no changing in their speeds
so what's changing them well actually
the answer is even more remarkable the
answer is that they're from Usain Bolt's
perspective that track is moving and
then because that truck is moving it
actually shrinks a little bit from his
perspective by about 50 minutes of a
nano meter so the key clocks are shorter
time basically because the track shrunk
a little bit for him so you could say he
didn't complete 100 meters which is
there to take his metal of it and each
one gives outside one ring and inside
the other where did you go
you